[Musik]
hallöchen meine süßen dieses rezept
werdet ihr alle lieben weil es ist eine
schokoladentorte dies erstens no big
zwar in soul latin oder agad ihnen
drittens einfach ohne robe oder sonst
etwas und trotzdem ist es richtig lecker
muss artig weich schokoladig unbedingt
nachmachen sage ich jetzt schon mal
einen kanal abonnieren wenn es noch
nicht gemacht habe und ich fange jetzt
auch schon direkt an der boden also
norek boden ist natürlich mit keksen und
in butter ich nehme heute oreo kekse
auch mit viel hoch geschlossen wenn man
auch mit füllung ist doch super wenn ihr
mal kekse zum verwerten dann könnt ihr
den rhein geben butterkekse und und und
was ich auch sehr mag ist sind die diese
luxus trip die sind auch leckeres
spekuliert was ihr möchtet hauptsache
die an in die einzel an gramm stimmen
also das netz 200 gramm aber die
mengenangaben schreibt ihr euch wie
immer unten in die video beschreibung
und das werde ich jetzt hier erstmal auf
einmal und dann kommt geschmolzene
butter nation das war schon das ist
unser boden
[Musik]
den keks boden gebe ich jetzt direkt
schon in den tortenring denen ich auf
eine tortenplatte gegeben habe das hat
den vorteil dass es nachher nicht mehr
transportieren müsst und jetzt ganz
einfach flach drücken ich nehme dafür
ganz einfach mal einen streich hilfe und
wirklich richtig flach drücken damit
dann später auch nichts mehr krümel und
der boden schon fest bleibt und jetzt
gehen wir den boden bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in die kühlung also
in den kühlschrank 15 minuten dauert 10
15 je nachdem wie schnell die gleich mit
der creme seit und dann geht es auch
schon weiter
und jetzt geht es weiter mit der geniale
schokoladencreme das sind auch nur fünf
zutaten benötigt aber vorab ganz ganz
wichtig die mascarpone muss
zimmertemperatur haben also die
mascarpone die ich verwende die habe ich
jetzt bereits stunden zuvor aus dem
kühlschrank genommen und einfach stehen
lassen mit zimmertemperatur und auch
sehr wichtig die schokolade ich habe
euch wie gesagt alles in die infobox sie
müsse 10x mitschreiben die schokolade
habe ich in der mikrowelle geschmolzen
geringe wattzahl und anschließend 20
minuten auskühlen lassen denn wenn ihren
temperaturunterschied habt dann
verklumpt die schokolade und dann wird
die creme iks daher darauf achten und
jetzt fahre ich zuallererst was capone
mit der schokolade
[Musik]
es sind mascarpone und schokolade
miteinander verbunden und es ist auch
wichtig dass ich hier wie ich in der
video beschreibung reingeschrieben habe
70 prozentige schokolade verwendet weil
auch wenn jetzt kein fan davon seit ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich weiß soll gesünder
sein aber ich mag es auch nicht jetzt so
zu schnecken aber in dieser torte
schmeckt viel besser weil sie eben nicht
so papi schmeckt wenn jetzt voll mich
nehmen weil ihr eben im alltag gerne
freue mich ist dann kann es sein dass es
zu süß wird und ich gebe daher jetzt
trotzdem zucker rhein zum ausgleich aber
es ist ein anderer geschmack als wenn
ihr jetzt voll mich nehmen wird so das
war mir ganz wichtig singen habe ich
nochmal erwähnt gebe jetzt hierzu eben
noch mal zucker und vanille extrakt das
hebt nochmaligen geschmack und macht so
ein bisschen feiner und nebenbei lässig
kalte schlagsahne in der küchenmaschine
aufschlagen
[Musik]
und ist die sahne steif und ich habe
heute kein sahne fest benutzt es ist
jetzt wichtig für die konsistent denn
wir wollen ja dass die sache jetzt so
ein bisschen also zwar fest aber faxen
gemacht hat der kamera nein das ist
richtig so das kann ich euch ja auch
zeigen mit sahne fest würde das ja nicht
passieren da wäre das richtig steif aber
wir wollen das gar nicht so damit die
konsistenz so ganz leicht muss artig
wird wenn es fertig ist und jetzt sie
heben wir die sahne einfach unter die
mascarpone schoko masse und am besten
nimmt ihr euch das find ich aber meine
juden haben sein
[Musik]
jetzt nimmt ihr euch einfach euren text
boden aus dem kühlschrank und gibt die
leckere schokoladencreme in den
tortenring und dann schön glatt
streichen
ich habe jetzt einen durchmesser von 20
zentimetern genommen daher komme ich mit
meinem standard linke paletten nicht
bereit und nehme mir deshalb wieder die
streiche fließt übrigens nur bestens
geeignet wenn ihr ebenso fälle habt wie
hier verlinkt ich euch ebenfalls in der
infobox und dann ganz einfach glatt
streichen ist habe ich hier schon
erledigt und jetzt bitte die kühl zeit
beachten nur sechs bis acht stunden je
nachdem wie keiner kühlschrank
eingestellt ist gerne auch über nacht
ich bin ein fan von über nacht
vorbereiten und am nächsten tag weiter
machen und haben sagt keine sorge er
guckt schon so verzweifelt hinter der
kamera weil die kühe zeit so lange ist
das schon vorbereitet daher bringe ich
den mist in den kühlschrank und bringen
sich bringen vorbereiteten jetzt einmal
her also bis gleich
[Musik]
und ob kommt jetzt noch eine richtig
leckere und weiche schokoladenglasur und
dafür nämlich ganz einfach schlagsahne
erhitzen sie in einem topf aber wirklich
vorsichtig erhitzen und sobald bläschen
anfängt zu steigen gebt ihr vollmilch
kuvertüre mit dazu dass das in der rest
hitze schmelzen
denn er hat an dieser stelle ausschalten
und dann noch einmal für fünf minuten an
die seite geben damit wir es nicht ganz
so heiß auf die oberfläche der gekühlten
torte geben und ich mach das jetzt ganz
vorsichtig und schwenken dann ganz
einfach die tonnen plätze damit sich das
verbindet und dann muss er nur noch die
schokoladen glasow aushärten und dann
war's das in dieser schokolade also ist
echt gut weil die ist ja ja aufgezeigt
damit das nicht so drauf knallt es so
sagte so sagte passieren ihr müsst
einfach nur meine perspektive manchmal
sehen also es ist immer so jaffé wollte
ich euch noch sagen genau was jetzt ein
konzept aber ich werde euch aber noch
sagen dass diese glas so dadurch dass du
jetzt ganz visana auch dazu nehmen dass
die so richtig schön soft ist aber das
steht er gleich beim anschnitt
[Musik]
und sobald die glasow dann fest wird das
dort zehn 15 minuten im kühlschrank ein
bisschen länger auf zimmertemperatur
dann könnt ihr sofort anschneiden und
genießen und diese torte wir jeden
überzeugen der auch nur ansatzweise
schokolade mag und jeden anderen sowieso
weil er einfach nicht so fest also nicht
so schwer im magen liegt ist nicht so
wichtig einfach mal ausprobieren
vertraut mir
ihr habt hier mal wieder die kiki
garantie auf dieses rezept das ist ein
unglaublich leckeres rezept ist ein
bisschen länger 10 wir geben zehn jahre
garantie auf jeden fall möchte ich das
in mir feedback das wir nicht mal
ausprobiert habe gerne auch mal einen
kommentar da lassen ich freue mich immer
sehr von euch zu lesen
was gibt es noch zu sagen abonniert habe
ich am anfang schon gesagt aber ich
denke dass all diejenigen die das ja und
auf install die liegen die wir uns schon
länger kennt sowieso abonniert haben
wenn nicht dann holt das nach und ganz
wichtig aktiviert die glocke weil ab und
zu laden wir mal ein video was nicht
sonntags oder mittwochs online geht und
dann seid ihr die ersten die das
erfahren so und jetzt würde ich euch
ganz viel freude beim nachmachen und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten ritchies
[Musik]